[Musique]
avec une chanson
imagination
je vous emmène dans votre idole
du bonheur tranquille
meurtri
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui périt
je m'appelle casini
la boule orange
[Musique]
si l'on
sait
pas moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né
manning a mis si j'aime eu la grâce au
son choix c'est pourquoi c'est mon droit
avec une chanson
un peu d'imagination
vous emmène dans notre hit i 2 au pays
du bonheur tranquille
c'est pour me rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'appelle quasi
j'ai une magma j ai une idée fantastique
je mens jeu doubi brigade
[Musique]
chimérique
à
cet endroit
endroit
avec une chanson
[Musique]
à
imagine as
[Musique]
en même temps d'autres ici
l'honneur remplie
silver au conflit
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
je m'appelle casini
[Musique]
oh
vous n'avez plus besoin de rien non ça
va j'ai tous mes bagages dans ce sac est
la grosse valise à ça on se colle pts
seulement quelques provisions pour la
route 1 à bien et il mourra pas très bon
et bien casimir je crois que nous
pouvons y aller allons-y pouvoir julie
mes amis comme vous voilà équipé nous
partons en voyage monsieur du snow est
en voyage mais voilà c'est passionnant
ces veinards vont faire une croisière
sur le casimir us premier le casimir us
premier lebrun du beau bateau du port
que juste le 6 9
mais pourquoi on y allez-vous par nos
chers amis malheureusement il faut bien
quelqu'un pour garder le jardin oui et
gentiment julie s'est dévoué là pour moi
vous monsieur de faire pourquoi ne
partiriez vous pas mais c'est une idée
ça ait de quoi le sommeil elle va nous
gâcher notre voyage je pourrais même
l'idée l'expédition promet vous savez le
voyage dure trois jours et la mer bouge
à voyage dure trois jours et la mer
bouches je crois que j'ai un travail
urgent je ne peux pas venir
les deux mécaniques à émir de frais mais
de me dire où vous allez et bien et nous
nous rendons sur l'île voisine où vivent
des cousins de casimir oui ils font là
bas un gloubi boulga à l'ananas
extraordinaire ces salles aventure on
invente une aventure casimir comme tu y
vas si tu voyages et en navigateur
solitaire comme l'auteur de ce livre que
je suis en train de lire ça oui cette
aventure lui il avait construit son son
radeau lui même quand on pense que toi
bien installée dans le casimir us
premier ça manque un petit peu d'imprévu
au bonjour mes amis
françois casimir j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous à quoi le casimir us
premier retarde son départ non une
malencontreuse panne de moteur
mais c'était pour rentable ça alors le
gloubiboulga n'aura peut être offrir ça
ne fait rien j 20 à la marge tu viens
avec moi qu'on soit à la nage en suisse
n'ont pas désigné non
sur c'est beaucoup trop loin oh là là je
suis vraiment déçu on en attend tu
parles à la réparation du casimir us
premier tout simplement là pour
longtemps factor où vous savez 27 july
et plusieurs heures et qui sait
peut-être plusieurs jours
non moi je ne peux pas attendre après
dix mois d'autres livres à monsieur du
sna très volontiers casimir tu pourras
connaître en imagination la véritable
aventure
en imagination c'est ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]